I started with the smiley face.
I added the meta tag with a character
set of utf-8 to the head of the page.
This is so
that Unicode characters get recognized.
Then all I had to do was go to
the Unicode site and copy and
paste this smiley face here.
To add the social media icons,
I added a link to Zocial in the head
using the weloveiconfonts website.
At the bottom of the page,
I added a footer tag with a div
inside with an id of social.
Inside, there are four a tags,
each of which has a different class.
Notice how all the classes
start with zocial, and
then a dash, and
then the Zocial icon that I wanted.
So I've got Twitter,
Facebook, Google+, and Digg.
I thought the logos looked just
a little bland on their own, so
I wound up using some CSS
to give them some shadows.
And in the end, I thought
the flourish was just a little silly.
So I added a slight border using
border-bottom to the end of the article.
I think this is a little bit classier
and it avoids some extra bytes for
the flourish.
You could have also used
some kind of svg here, but
I decided to go with a little
bit more subtle approach.
Oh, and here's my svg logo.
It's pretty simple, so I just simply
inlined it here inside the header.
All right.
This blog is looking
much more reasonable.
We've dropped some unnecessary bytes in,
added some social media icons.
At the end of the next lesson,
you'll have one more opportunity to
really make this blog's images shine.